Minneapolis burns Minneapolis is burning
down because of riots that or have come
in response to this video it's going
viral this is the police involved
killing of George Floyd I think we at
this point we've probably all seen the
video people are talking about this
mostly from a political perspective or a
social perspective or the perspective of
civil unrest I've heard very little
analysis on the actual killing itself
I've heard very little analysis from the
perspective of law enforcement or the
the actual arrest fortunately we are
joined now by someone who can offer some
of that perspective a very prominent
youtuber who is also or was a patrol
officer and SWAT team member now serves
as public information officer this is
officer 401 you've probably seen the
videos if you haven't yet we will get a
law enforcement perspective on the
arrest itself officer 401 thank you for
coming on the show thank you very much
for having me sir so officer when you
look at the video itself can you take us
through what the arrest should have
looked like what it did look like what
you're seeing that maybe the rest of us
who were just laymen or civilians are
missing he was very calm it was there
there was no rush to to render any sort
of any sort of aid to him or to check on
his well-being I'm not sure what he was
waiting for but the fact that his you
know his knee was on this guy's neck for
an extended amount of time is completely
unacceptable
you know once once he was secured
properly with handcuffs he should have
been at least rolled over to his stomach
if not taking up off the ground and put
on his feet when you see these videos
you just never know because there have
been cases where people have said this
is a clear example of police brutality
and then some new evidence will emerge
and you say okay actually maybe it
wasn't police brutality but this one
seemed pretty clear-cut I mean it seemed
like like the officer was was clearly in
the wrong here and that seems to be what
what you were observing is well how
prevalent is this what should be done in
this case what is usually done in this
case I mean can you can you pull back
the curtain
little bit on on maybe what comes next
well you know I recently actually
yesterday I just I put out another video
about you know the the perspective from
cell phones doesn't always tell the
entire story yeah you know there was
there was a recent case in in Delaware
where somebody recorded a man that was
apparently being beaten by by two police
officers and when you watch the actual
body cam footage that was released after
that it tells the entire story
unfortunately with the case with George
Floyd really no matter which angle you
look at it it's wrong and it's bad day
for law enforcement and you know you you
hear you know people saying that cops
have each other's backs and this and
that and that's really not true because
even today you know being at the police
department everybody just shaking their
heads at how negligent this was for that
officer and how it paints a depiction
for all of us when that's very much not
the case that does seem to be why these
particular very sad cases crop up so
much and become sensationalized it seems
they become sensationalized precisely
because they are rare you know and and
you you don't see viral videos of the
vast majority of law enforcement
officers who are doing their jobs and
keeping communities safe you know even
even getting past the prevalence here or
you know how widespread a problem is
because I think the statistics are
pretty clear on it what do you make of
images that we saw last night of the
police precinct burning to the ground
you know rioters burning the place down
and the elected politicians basically
saying yeah officers should stand down a
band in the building and let the riots
burn well it's it's kind of you're kind
of between a rock and a hard place well
I am as far as my opinion just because I
understand why people are protesting I'd
like that
I think that people have gotten to the
point where they feel that their voices
aren't being heard loud enough so
they're going to extreme measures to
make sure they're heard unfortunately
those extreme measures are costing other
people's lives and livelihoods that had
nothing to do with the incident you know
if you have to judge the officers on a
case-by-case basis you can't do it
you know as an overall and certainly
burning down a police department is not
going to be beneficial to your cause
right very quickly and we've got about
30 seconds left but I know that this
officer who was involved has now been
arrested he is going to be charged you
know what is the crime here how do you
see it playing out I see it as homicide
I mean there really to me there is no
other way I mean it's murder all day
long there is no other way you know I've
been doing this for 12 and 1/2 years I
have experience on SWAT this all day
long to me is murder he never even
checked the well-being of his suspect
and that's our job when we have somebody
in custody it is our responsibility to
ensure their well-being and safety yeah
that's it seems pretty clear-cut but I'm
glad that we can get the perspective of
someone who actually knows what he's
talking about here to to back that up
officer 401 go check him out on YouTube
videos are very informative officer
thank you so much for being here thank
you very much for having me sir
[Music]
[Music]